d'ailleurs en immobilier on observe
aussi une accélération de la
construction les mises en chantier ont
bondi de 15 % en juillet si vous
combinez ce phénomène là à la grève au
port de montréal et à d'autres facteurs
dont la pandémie c'est suffisant pour
déséquilibrer toute l'industrie du bois
d'oeuvre
il ya des détaillants d'ailleurs qu'ils
disent vivre une pénurie de bois en ce
moment on m'en parlait avec jean
françois samray il est président
directeur général du conseil de
l'industrie forestière du québec
bonsoir monsieur samrin bons seront
bonnes cet art ne sais quoi
l'approvisionnement l'état en ce moment
de l'industrie et pour le bois d'oeuvre
le bois de construction à ce qu'a
vraiment pénurie et comme vous l'avez
mentionné je pense qu'on constate une
augmentation de la demande plusieurs
personnes ont décidé de passer des
vacances à la maison de faire des
travaux de construction s'est
particulièrement ces produits qui donc
de d2 par quatre donc arbois de résine
aux deux résident qui sont à demander
même ceux qui sont traitées pour faire
des patios des des galeries ça c'est
vraiment une grande rupture de stock
pour le moment mais comme vous l'avez
bien mentionné il ya une réalité qu'on a
vécu la crise la grève au cn
il ya là qu'ovide et il ya maintenant la
grève au port qui est wolf qui affecte
certains de nos membres donc pour le
bois de ce que signifie ce c'est qu'il y
à une demande qui est grande et le fait
de pouvoir exporter le papier vient
limiter la capacité de production des
séries donc ce qui n'était pas le
problème donc c'est un tout on peut
difficilement décerné discerner les deux
2 aussi ouais bon en ce moment parce
qu'il y en ce qui concerne la grève au
port de montréal vous parlez pas ty
d'exportation qui sont ralenties dans
quelle mesure la saa fait que les
activités l'industrie forestière
il est évident que quand un arbre est
récoltée on vend on va se servir d'une
partie de larmes pour faire du sciage et
peut donc pour faire les matériaux de
construction et l'autre partie va
observer pour faire des copeaux et
servir à la pâte et donc si un des
secteurs ne tourne au ralenti l'autre ne
peut pas tourner les régimes parce que
il va se construire derrière les
scieries des montagnes de copeaux et ils
ont des décisions des obligations
environnementales à respecter donc c'est
un tout c'est comme si je vous
écoutez andré vous allez devoir
fonctionner avec on va vous emmener
votre foi mais vous conservez votre
coeur et au poumon
donc vous allez pouvoir rester en vie la
réponse est probablement vraiment pas du
tout donc c'est un tout l'industrie
forestière c'est la récolte c'est le
sillage c'est les pâtes et papiers il le
touche fonctionne vraiment ensemble donc
c'est un écosystème que quand on est
infecté l'autre les difficultés est ce
que vous savez des solutions de rechange
monsieur samri bon là c'est bloqué au
port mais il ya le ferroviaire il ya le
transport par camion bon ça coûte plus
cher mais ce cas quand même des
solutions mais pour ce qui est du bois
de sciage la majorité se transporte par
camion ou par train donc ça peut
continuer
et c'est sur un marché continental donc
le bois du québec va d'abord à lui même
alimenté le marché québécois mais il y
en a également qui est exportée quand on
parle d'une secteur des jus papier des
pâtes et papiers et le québec est le
premier producteur mondial dans ce
secteur là ça se fait très grande
majorité par le bateau et dire on va
mettre ça dans des tringles pour aller à
amener ce dans d'autres ports c'est pas
une situation qui peut se faire parce
que le réseau ferroviaire lui est déjà
et tirait son maximum par les autres
industries qui essaient de se
repositionner dons pour le secteur du
départ et papiers québécois
c'est fondamental que le conflit se
règle très rapidement déjà que bon dans
l'industrie forestière les installations
si je comprends bien tournée déjà au
ralenti pandémie oblige vous faites quoi
le bilan du printemps et puis on a
réussi se faire placer sur les listes
déposées des biens essentiels parce
qu'on se rappelle rock de du des
produits de pâtes et papiers il y en a
des masques oms est utilisé pour faire
des masques c'est pour faire des blues
il rien qui est transporté dans un
hôpital
si c'est pas dans dans des boîtes et du
cartonnage et en plus des produits
d'autres produits similaires qui sont
essentiels à la simulation et au
maintien des règles sanitaires dont on
réussisse à placer un taux mais
néanmoins comme vous le dites il ya une
demi
option de vente dans différents secteurs
qui ont diminué la demande et le secteur
du papier journal est un secteur qui a
beaucoup souffert
- de réclames publicitaires - de moins
de demande mondiale donc ce secteur qui
est que ce faire néanmoins comme je vous
ai expliqué ce secteur qui est
fondamental l'écosystème forestier
québécois et en ce qui concerne le bois
en particulier bon le phénomène de
pénurie veut dire aux deux prises sept
en progression en ce moment là oui c'est
une situation que dans le bois de
résineux je le répète s'appelle le pain
le mélèze c'est ce secteur est en
augmentation c'est pas le cas des autres
bois failli mais c'est une transition il
ya une demande plus grande
l'offre n'a pas suivi donc il ya un
marché qui vote qui cherche un équilibre
et qu' une hausse de prix mais la
réalité c'est que ce prix ne va pas
demeurer éternellement
et ces mêmes c'est même nuisible pour
l'industrie donc les situations vont
faire en sorte que de nouveaux
fournisseurs vont apparaître des
scieries qui n'étaient pas rentables
vont peut-être ouvrir ou aux etats-unis
pour répondre à cette demande et il ya
un marché européen qui eux sont en train
de convertir leur usine pour répondre
aux standards nord américain dès des
dimensions donc son prix continue de
monter tout le temps du côté de l'offre
il va se passer quelque chose
l'industrie québécoise
nous ce qu'on souhaite c'est obtenir un
niveau de marché un niveau de prix de
long terme d'équilibré de long terme
pour continuer la transition
technologique du secteur de la forêt au
québec c'est fondamental et c'est la
compétitivité de long terme de
l'industrie qui était pourtant puis qui
la forêt c'est également la possibilité
de capter du carbone donc nous on vit
sur notre certification environnementale
votre mea je suis à murray et bien
entendu on doit s'arrêter là si
malheureusement je vous remercie d'avoir
un terrain parfait madame st-arnaud
merci